[Music]
so a few years ago
when twitter was actually not just a
cesspool
jimmy kimmel uh would go on and read
jimmy reads mean tweets and we stole it
from him and started doing you know
tweets that are mean about us because
they're fabulous
they're so fun and a lot of them are
like the high school students going
through the curriculum and stuff and uh
a lot of them are forced against their
will
and a lot of them are just you know
people can just they you know they have
digital courage these are things and you
would never say stuff like this to
somebody's face because you get your
face punched in but um
[Laughter]
but you know people people say anything
on the internet and it's so cute
so we wanted to bring it back um
dave reads mean tweets and george looks
at the comments so george you're get you
get trashed on youtube yeah yeah not as
much on twitter but youtube they're big
fans of leaving me some some love okay
so you you're gonna read some of the
things said about me i guess yes all
right man i've been waiting a long time
for this dave
don't take it personal okay
all right i could take it out on you but
oh you will soon because you get to read
my comments oh there we go herman said
impulse buying an xbox feels great when
you ain't got a dave ramsey in your ear
good stuff from herman there yeah
herman's
emotional
until his emotional what 13 years old
he's got to be yeah okay
money mitch said who named dave ramsey
king of finance for every christian
church is king of finance like burger
king i like that does that look like
that she'll get you a little crown get
me a little burger give me a little king
of finance crown i need a little crown
oh here's one uh username boycott delta
that's interesting after our delta rant
earlier
he said i've listened to a lot of dave
ramsey i'm convinced he quite literally
doesn't know how credit cards work he's
become a victim of his own
oh
propaganda
deep
that is deep
but it's all on the premise that i don't
understand how a credit card works which
is that's kind of humorous yeah the the
two sentences don't make sense together
but that's twitter for you all right
carly said if my mama doesn't stop
pushing dave ramsey on me i swear
with a little crying face
she's very upset yeah she's 19.
i don't blame her if her mom back off i
work using me as a weapon
just why don't you push like common
sense on her instead of dave ramsey
that's better i think that i think she's
probably right we're just getting warmed
up here hey maker said dave ramsey is a
charlatan hypocrite and basic piece of
beep
you can guess what word that was you
know here's a you know think about it
that comes up charlatan shows up a lot
after my name which is the three fans
that's a 10 word i know and here's the
thing i was thinking about this um i
read one of these other day and it
popped into my head how many times are
you at a party and you use the word
charlatan zero i mean how many times do
you have in a sentence with normal human
beings you use the word charlatan well
if they're talking about you maybe at
parties i don't know it could be it
could be it could be it's a an anti-dave
party but um
but i mean it's not it's just not
something it comes up only on the
internet it's my point oh yeah it only
comes up when you're not real a real
person having a real conversation you
would use the word hypocrite
or piece of bleep you would do that i
personally wouldn't you wouldn't but
people would but they don't say
charlatan so-and-so is a charlatan they
don't bring their well if if you're a
keyboard warrior you want to look smart
oh yeah
and the thing is it had to it had a
spell check
yeah because you couldn't spell it no
okay they probably started with an s and
got it wrong yeah all right brian moody
said dave ramsey is good for people to
clean up a financial mess and get their
house in order he started out nice
but wealthy people don't baby step
okay so the
45
millionaires we've talked to on the air
this year we started tracking
millionaires we talked to on the air
so since january when on this show we've
talked to 45 millionaires
i guess they would beg to differ he has
a different definition of millionaires
maybe or wealthy yeah
wealthy people there we go kyle henkel
said i think dave ramsey financial
advise is cringy
cringy there's a lot of misspellings
there but you know what they're
really funny
but wait but you know what i yeah uh it
is cringy it's so cringe dave dead free
oh it is it's cringy because it's it
like it says
ooh you have to sacrifice to win that is
cringy that's so cringe no it is i mean
it's like that's kind of like ugh i
don't i kind of agree with him get with
the times dave people don't want to hear
that
all right addy said proud owner of a new
tacoma if dave ramsey found out he'd
probably 360 no scope me
i had to look this one up dave this is a
call of duty reference in which a player
spins around with the rifle and shoots
with no scope killing their target let
me help you with this he didn't really
because it's not a real rifle it's on a
video game
call of duty is available they're
assuming that you are playing call of
duty and well yeah so
so i'm gonna
i'm gonna
fake kill him on a fake game is that
that's how the metaverse works that's
what happens if you buy a tacoma i fake
kill you on a fake game you just
described them at a verse then you
finally got it i finally got it okay
uh jen said in my head i mixed up dave
ramsey and gordon ramsay and really
thought all this time that gordon ramsay
was giving financial advice in addition
to this the clip of gordon ramsay
somebody said who's dave ramsey he's
like bleep bleep bleep bleep dave rosie
please please please yes it's hilarious
there's there's those three at the
grocery store and gordon ramsay's
helping them shop and the guy
accidentally says dave ramsey instead of
gordon and he goes i'm not bleeping dave
ramsey it was a great clip that's so
funny he's a great last one for you also
cool kid with uh a k and a k said dave
ramsey is a coke head and then
parentheses this is libel spelled wrong
actually he spelled it out it's liberal
spelled it but
wow well clearly air dave are you a
cokehead and is that liable
i
i hadn't had a coke in a long time i
quit drinking coke
he did i got a big head i got a big head
does that count like a big basketball
head that counts
does that count i feel like if you if
you were a cokehead we'd have a very
different shell on our hands
well yeah cause the caffeine and
coca-cola will that's what lights you up
that's so true
all right dave my turn i get a few
boomers i don't have as many all right
david says uh george gives worthless
advice the absolute worst of all ramsey
personalities yikes george what's scary
is i'm just giving the advice you would
have given so what does that say about
you
oh my goodness
yeah since they all kind of say the same
thing but with different tones that's
hurtful yeah that's true all right
janelle and she says this like once a
week this is normal for george chanel
this janelle's like she's like head of
your anti-fan club hey i'll take it any
pr is good pr they say george has the
charisma of a wet sock
sorry man at least she apologized right
after yeah that's just passive
aggressive but yeah but is it wet sock
has no disrespect no disrespect right
after they disrespect you that's always
that's like throwing that on the end
because it negates it yeah wouldn't a
dry sock have less charisma
i feel like if something's dry it has
even less i don't know janelle i don't
know how you measure saw charisma no i
don't know what to measure on soccer all
right
all right who is the nerd in glasses
giving advice well we both have glasses
on is he new or something
oh boy no i've actually lost weight i
look about you look great dave and i
don't think you're a nerd i think you're
just intellectual does does dahloney
wear glass he doesn't wear glasses no
i'm not just me and you hold him down
yeah cause rachel had glasses before she
got like that the glass the uh eye thing
done oh yeah and it looked like coke
bottle bottoms i mean she looked like
the kid there was a guy on office space
you remember that neither stapler oh
yeah that's what her glasses we both
have terrible uh eyesight me and rachel
here's the thing people say is he new or
something and i've been here nine years
guys get a clue
are you new
whatever george came off as a little rat
bag at first
but he's grown on me
he's consistent and he's logical oh
that's a comment i thought you were just
telling me
i said james said this james smith not
james
sir james not james in the booth james
smith said this which is probably i'm
sure his real name so it started what is
a rat bag i don't know it just sounds
like a bag of rats it's a bag of rats i
guess
came off as little i guess a little
condescending know-it-all little you
know punchable phase type guy well yeah
but i mean
he could have just said a little rat i
don't know what a bag of rats is i don't
know but at least he he then went he's
he's grown on me he's consistent he's
logical so i'll take that
he's a he's a logical consistent little
ratbag i'm trying to end it on a
positive note for you thank you james
this is just james actually letting us
know how he feels about us and he just
changes the names james wrote always
that's cruel man
kelly wrote some of them i know she did
here's my worry dave people are now
going to write in specifically
hoping to get their their mean tweet on
the show so we're never doing this again
because we're thin skinned and our
feelings are hurt
and i'm gonna have to go home and
cry
because you
three of you don't like me on the
internet
this is the ramsey show